l'inquiétude des patients placé
sous-répirateurs artificiels et
hospitalisés à domicile ils ont appris
hier par la voix du porte-parole
Bénédicte qu'ils pourront comme tous les
Français être ponctuellement privés
d'électricité cet hiver ils sont
délestables ces personnes-là ils sont
non prioritaires si je peux me permettre
de le dire ainsi pour autant on a une
attention particulière à leur égard
avez-vous pensé aux milliers de
personnes sous assistance respiratoires
au porteur d'un coeur artificiel qui
doivent recharger leurs batteries nos
concitoyens doivent-ils investir dans
des groupes électrogènes en urgence
madame la Première ministre la polémique
enfle les prend une dimension politique
une situation ahurissante pour Marine Le
Pen une mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui pour ce député de la France
insoumise donc je le redis notre
engagement de tous les instants c'est de
mobiliser chacun pour assurer la
sécurité d'approvisionnement en
électricité notre responsabilité c'est
de planifier tous les scénarios sans
faux semblant mais sans AG de fausses
perles ce débat est absurde
étape sur le rôle des autorités
publiques des entreprises publiques ça
n'est pas de transférer la peur ni de
gouverner par la peur et donc le rôle du
gouvernement des ministres des
opérateurs c'est de faire leur travail
pour fournir de l'énergie nous sommes à
la masse des stages
sur les prévisions de RTL qui l'ont dit
très clairement ces scénarios extrêmes
il intervient qu'on ultime recourt pour
protéger notre système énergétique
je suis français j'aime pas trop qu'on
m'explique qu'il faut que je fasse chez
moi ou ce qu'il faut pas que je fasse
mais il y a un truc que j'aime encore
moins c'est l'idée de me retrouver sans
courant à l'heure où je dois préparer
mes gamins ça veut dire qu'on va tous
faire collectivement les moments où il y
aura des tensions qui sont anticipées on
va tous faire collectivement un petit
geste supplémentaire et donc je demande
à chacun de faire son travail le travail
de déesse c'est de faire tourner les
centrales le travail du gouvernement
c'est qu'il y a une planification le
travail de tout le monde c'est qu'on
déroule la sobriété les scénarios de la
peur pas pour moi on demande parfois de
différer de quelques minutes l'allumage
de certains appareils comme le
lave-lingembre
malheureusement le président de la
République ne sait pas où il en est et
que sa patauge ça mouline et que
malheureusement comme bien souvent
lorsque c'est flou c'est qu'il y a un
loup un discours super anxiogène
c'est-à-dire qu'on a d'un côté le
président de la République qui dit pas
de panique et moi ce matin j'étais
invité par le préfet de mon département
à une vision comme tous les maires et
les parlementaires de l'Essonne sur la
question de comment vont s'organiser les
délaissages et quand même la
démonstration de l'extraordinaire
régression de notre pays tout cela va
avoir des conséquences sur des Français
qui vont très certainement perdre leur
emploi sur les chefs d'entreprise qui
vont devoir fermer leur entreprise je
rappelle que la France est le pays
européen qui a le plus de retard en
matière de développement des énergies
renouvelables et d'une certaine manière
on le paye aujourd'hui avec la question
des coupures d'électricité au siège de
la brigade de protection des mineurs la
garde à vue du youtubeur a été prolongée
norman Thavaud 35 ans devrait être
confronté aujourd'hui à cette jeune
Québécoise Maggie démarrait il y a plus
de deux ans et la portée plainte pour
corruption de mineurs et depuis elle
affirme avoir reçu une trentaine de
témoignages d'autres victimes sur les
réseaux sociaux des femmes qui
l'accusent de viol était mineur au
moment des fées l'affaire Norman révélée
et quelques jours seulement après celle
d'un autre youtuber Léo Grasset alias
dirty bylologie vulgarisateur
scientifique déjà accusé de harcèlement
et visé par une enquête pour viol sur
une étudiante après Nagui Desmarais 5
autres femmes ont porté plainte contre
norman Thavaud cette fois pour viol son
avocate ne nous a pas répondu hier soir
le groupe webedia premier producteur
français de contenu Web s'est écarté du
YouTube en 2018 le plus célèbre d'entre
eux Lucas hauchar alias Squeezie tentait
déjà d'alerter les youtubeurs y compris
ceux qui crient sur tous les toits
qu'ils sont féministes qui profitent de
la vulnérabilité psychologique de jeunes
abonnés pour obtenir des rapports
sexuels on vous voit la vérité finit
toujours par éclater